knowing what you know now if you had
people insulated in the administration
right that basically hated Trump which
is insane to me like we have people like
General Kelly I mean think about General
Kelly was the chief of staff yeah that
is one of the most powerful people in
the world and I love them Marine Corps
is my favorite service I spent two and a
half years teaching at quantica I love
the Marines and it pains me to say he
was a subversive he should be in prison
right now I mean to think of this Corey
Lewandowski
Good Buds with the president never
worked in the administration but he'd
come in all the time to talk to the
president and he'd never tell Kelly
Kelly would get irate he'd get pissed
and I can tell you this because Corey
said this in a fox interview one day he
was coming out of the oval Kelly saw
Corey
grabbed Corey and flung him against the
wall so hard he ripped the button off
his jacket General Kelly did that
generally now and said you don't effing
come in my building without my
permission he was chief of staff at the
time my building nobody freaking elected
you to nothing oh yeah you're a big you
know Marine retire nobody elected my
building that cannot happen again what
are we going to do about it
um there's only two jobs I'd be prepared
to do in the next Administration one of
those Personnel
um there's another person who's already
been um that given the
nod yeah and he's a friend of mine and
if he gets it we've had a discussion
I'll help you in whatever way you need
Reagan said it best policy is Personnel
Personnel is policy it doesn't matter
what your issue is I'm a big Second
Amendment guy but whether it's a
sanctity of life whether it's the Border
whether it's economy it doesn't matter
what your issue is if you don't get
Personnel right
you're not going to get anything done
rule number one if we win if we do a
part we have to have a filter system
that only allows people who love America
into the building end of story so it's
not about Trump it's not about
Republicans people who love America who
would those names be meaning you know
the last because the criticism is some
of the older guys don't want to come
back you know this person's not coming
back daughter's not coming back cushions
after this one nobody wants a job back
everybody's kind of hesitating who would
be departed a new team yeah so this is
I'm working on an article that's exactly
those for my sub stack you know the the
names of the cabinet and who should come
in
this is this is a challenge
my friend has the morning show in DC
Chris Plante great radio host and he
said one of the greatest successes of
the left in the last 20 years is to
guarantee that good men and women will
never work in a republican conservative
Administration
and he's right why would you why would
you be a Justice Kavanaugh even why
would you risk having you know loonies
come to your house with zip ties and a
gun to kill you and your children I you
know I'm you I thought I was used to it
but then when I came into the
administration they came after my wife
they came after my son there was one
journalist wrote 52 hit pieces in me on
me in two months one of which was about
my 18 year old son and used the word
traitor in the headline
about my high school age son why would
you do that
so it's going to be a challenge what
what I said to Mike Flynn at the
beginning the National Security advisor
I said because we inherited a National
Security Council there's 420 people it
was insane Obama created this massive
massive NSC and I said Mike get rid of
them all send them back to their
agencies because most of them come from
you know state or CIA or DOD and put
some good people at the top of each one
as senior directors and then let's fill
it with people from the campaign that's
bringing people who work their ass off
to get president Trump elected who don't
know the difference between Sunni and
Shia but give me six months and I will
train them I will I will be there they
will be there till 10 o'clock at night
they will learn the rudiments of
national security and at least they'll
be loyal to the will of 64 million
Americans and and you know a week later
Mike was fired
so you want to bring in Greenies or do
you want to bring in some big news well
I think we've got it we've got a year
and a half no we got it we got a year
and a half to find Cadre and to convince
people uh we've got to have the Top Line
locked in we've got to have the cabinet
members we've got to have the senior
directors we've got to have the dazdies
the assistant secretaries all locked in
but it can't be we I don't want to get
into too much in the way and tell me if
I'm talking too much
all the big appointments used to go
through our office through bannon's
office so we'd get these spreadsheets
every week of people who want to come
into the administration there was one
spreadsheet we received this is
unclassified of people who are applying
to the top jobs in the dod like
assistant Secretary of Defense Deputy
assistant Secretary of Defense and I
looked at the spreadsheet before I gave
it to Bannon I said
where are we getting these names because
there's a column on the right hand side
referred by
four of the people on this spreadsheet
had been referred by Michelle Flournoy
Michelle Flournoy was Obama's you know
top Pentagon official people people
actually coming into the Trump
Administration are putting Michelle
Flournoy I mean just put you know
podesta just put Axelrod why don't you
that can't happen again that cannot
happen again
yeah it's going to be you know that that
part is going to be uh interesting to
watch who's part of the cabin and who's
part of the team because some people the
criticism of uh uh first term was the
fact that the training of the swamp
didn't happen and I wonder is it is a
part of it
where you know you know how in fights uh
or you know a game you lose the game and
you know the opponent hug each other or
even in UFC hey man this was a great
fight you know you're really great you
know you really brought it and I got to
give some respect to him you know this
fight wouldn't be displaying you become
friends is it almost there's a side of
you when you go into this space that is
filled with you know backstabbing dirty
and you're like you know what I think
they're gonna be Noble so let me have a
meeting with Romney the next day you
know let me bring these other guys in
and then you're like let's make this
work maybe I can change them maybe if
they really see how good I am we can
really unify this group and then you
make the mistake of keeping the comeys
keeping everybody yeah no no no no no no
no they're not who you think they are
this is not capitalism this is not
business this is not corporate these
guys are darker and dirtier than you
think stay strong and bring True
Believers in is that the evolution that
he had to go through with his first term
you and also he's in a territory that
he's never been in before right I'm I'm
a geopolitics guy I'm a broadcaster
don't ask me to play your concert piano
it's not you will have a very bad
concert or who won the uh Celtics he
came nuggets or whatever it was right no
clue is that a cricket match right
um so he's in a completely new
environment but but to your point two
things let's talk about the left let's
talk about our side on our side The
Establishment really thinks he's a joke
he's an anomaly that the American people
just chose the wrong person by accident
they really I mean Chris Christie's
going to announce Chris Jabba the
heart's gonna announce it does he really
think that anybody in America is going
to vote for him I mean ASA Hutchinson
ASA Hatcher you could literally be a
diplodocus from prehistoric times and
you're running for the presidency The
Establishment thinks that Donald Trump
is a blip it's a it's an accident we're
gonna get back to normal and footsie
under the table the Democrats and the
sweet deals with China and will be fine
he's just he's just weird just an
accident it's perverse get back to
normal so you can't deal with those guys
because they think you're a freak
and the other side let me give you an
example
I was thrown in day three of the
administration right because we dropped
the travel ban and it was not well
communicated and I could see that it
wasn't being well communicated so I
texted Bannon on a Friday night I said
Steve you know we've got to explain this
better like this isn't anti-muslim this
is based upon a threat assessment that
Obama left us of the Seven Nations that
cannot tell us who the people are who
are coming across the border this is
their threat assessment we're just
initiating it
and and Bannon typical Bannon it doesn't
sleep 3 A.M he takes me back he says
tell Spicer now to use you now I didn't
go into the administration to do media I
went there to do behind the scenes
National Security so okay Spicer a
balance says use me so I am literally
dropped into the pit of Hell the
Saturday morning Sunday Friday doing all
the CNN I mean this is the fun stuff
that people keep talking to me about
when I destroyed Cuomo when I was on
with you know MSNBC and I was a
effective communicator
after I was effectively communicating
all this stuff for the president
Senator Durbin wrote a letter to the
Secretary of Homeland Security to
investigate my naturalization and to
have me
kicked out of the country
Dick Durbin from Illinois
these this is this isn't a political
difference
this is what when the other side thinks
you must have lied on your immigration
papers you must be deported because
you're an effective Communicator for the
president
right
this isn't politics this isn't you know
Tip O'Neill having a beer with Ronald
Reagan
you know Friday night the left wants to
destroy us every week they got together
every week once upon a time there was a
time in this country where tip and Gip
would get together and have lunch in
Rose Garden and there was a certain
nobility of it
um of where they were let me ask you a
question let me just add to that think
think about what Brennan has said
Brennan John Brennan still has his
security clearances he's a former CIA
director he on National cable television
he said the incumbent president
is a Trader who works for Russia
excuse me I mean politics has been
dirtier for a long time but to say the
guy in the White House
actually works for the Kremlin
that's not politics
that's evil so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]